good evening and welcome to fox news
primetime
[Music]
i'm lawrence jones here in new york and
tonight i have some news that will
downright
shock you brand new poland from fox news
tonight
the majority of americans 60 percent of
them that's right do not trust the
federal government
and the distrust largely follows along
party lines only 16 percent of
republicans
and only 25 percent of independents say
they trust the feds
now that's compared to 55 percent of
democrats of course
now i know what you're thinking how is
that possible our government is so
honest and transparent
and constantly acts in the best interest
of its citizens what's not to trust
if the past year is any example a whole
hell of a lot
let's start with the handling of the
pandemic remember two weeks to slow the
spread
and then that two weeks became two
months then six then a whole damn year
and then there was this stay safe by
washing your hands
by covering your cough by staying home
if you're sick
masks do not work for the general public
and preventing them from getting corona
virus
then a few months later they changed
their minds saying that they were trying
to stop a run on ppe
when it came time to reopen schools the
federal government gave states to cover
to keep them closed
even when we knew it was safe for our
kids to return
then they lied to us saying they didn't
cave to the teachers unions on reopening
guidelines
only to have the head of the union come
out and admit
they did just that how about immigration
for months the biden administration got
up on the podium and told us that there
was no crisis at the border
when we could see for ourselves it was
the exact opposite
and now months later after finally
admitting there was a crisis
they told us kamala harris was going to
fix it once again we can see for
ourselves
now everything is infrastructure even
things that are not
child care paid leave care giving those
are the same thing as bridges and
tunnels but somehow even more expensive
they tell us climate change is going to
end the world in 12 years
they told us that there was russian
collusion that tell us that
every part of our government is racist
and death desperately needs to be fixed
look we know we're not perfect but
things are getting better every day
and it's not just about telling the
truth it's about competent governance
i don't trust the government to respect
my freedoms protect my civil rights or
even spend my tax dollars with a shed of
responsibility
yeah i don't even trust them to properly
fix my potholes
and to be clear this is nothing new we
have not trusted our federal government
for a long time
the last time more than half of
americans trusted the federal government
was in
2002 in the second year of the bush
administration
and in hindsight we probably should have
had not been so
trusting them hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else